foreign
[Music]
we talk about a whole range of exciting
topics including some big news about DC
a fresh announcement about the upcoming
Dune series plus details about the
future of the controversial She-Hulk
series
at the beginning of October we reported
on the signing of two leading actresses
for the upcoming series June The
Sisterhood and now a new cast member has
joined the prequel the talk is of Indira
barma who became known to a larger
audience through Game of Thrones and the
British TV series paranoid to name but a
few in Dune The Sisterhood she plays
Empress Natalya who strictly speaking is
not part of the 2012 book by Brian
Herbert the son of Dune Creator Frank
Herbert bear the empresses tabrina and
orena make an appearance and it is
assumed that Natalya will be a composite
of both characters she is presumably
married to Emperor Salvador the first or
his predecessor Jules from the Carino
line depending on what the series
creators decide on and whether she is
based more on tabrina or orena since the
new character Natalya is described as
extremely formidable in her appearance
we imagine that she would be closer to
arena in terms of plot since her husband
Jules died in the course of the story
making her the rightful Empress either
way it will be interesting to see how
this new character will find her way in
the Dune Universe the series is set just
about 10 000 years before the film
series and focuses on two har Khan and
sisters who found a Sisterhood that
later becomes the Benny Jesuit Swedish
Chernobyl director Johann rank has been
hired to direct the first two episodes
of Dune The Sisterhood while Empire
producer Diane adimo John will take over
as showrunner we are looking forward to
receiving more news but unfortunately a
release date is still unknown
shooting of the upcoming Indiana Jones 5
has been wrapped up since February and
now it is being reported that leading
man Harrison Ford is in talks for his
next role almost 56 years after his
screen debut the meanwhile 80 year old
is to portray a character in the MCU
namely that of General Thaddeus Ross the
U.S Air Force Lieutenant General is a
talented tactician and his skills mainly
include leading military units in tricky
situations the character made his first
MCU movie appearance back in 2008 the
Incredible Hulk where he took military
action against Bruce Banner Ross was
last seen in Black Widow where he was
played by William Hurt just as before
unfortunately William Hurt passed away
earlier this year leaving the role
vacant and now to be filled by Harrison
Ford as has been officially confirmed
thus the rumors of last month are true
that Ford is the desired cast for this
role as deadline and others report Ford
is now assuming the role of General Ross
for the first time in Captain America
new world order and is expected to
reprise it later in Thunderbolts in
addition the continuation of the film
character increases the likelihood that
the Red Hulk will also be established in
the MCU after all not only is he Bruce
Banner's greatest enemy but also none
other than General Ross himself we are
eagerly awaiting official news and are
looking forward to Captain America New
World Order on May 3rd 2024 as well as
Thunderbolts on July 26 2024. by the way
the filming of Captain America 4 will
start in early 2023 so Ford doesn't have
that much time left to get ready
this week there was a true sensation at
DC with The Hollywood Reporter
announcing a whole series of new
projects the Highlight is certainly a
Man of Steel sequel which has been a big
dream for many fans for many years Henry
Cavill has played the role of the alien
superhero in three dceu films and rumor
has it that the 39 year olds returned to
a starring role is more likely than ever
it has been rumored for years that he
will embody Superman once again
especially since he himself didn't mince
his words when asked for his opinion as
the character lies very close to his
heart now under the direction of Justice
League producer Charles rovin A
screenwriter is being sought as is a
director who would like to handle the
directing Christopher Macquarie is
particularly high up on the list of
possible contenders although at this
time he has his hands full with Mission
Impossible 7 and 8 making a take on the
project rather unlikely speaking of time
Henry Cavill also has a packed schedule
at the moment which is mainly down to
his leading role in The Witcher series
if many substantial rumors are to be
believed Cabell will be making at least
a cameo appearance in Black Adam which
hit theaters on October 21st in fact
Dwayne Johnson did not grow tired of
mentioning his fellow actor and his
character at every opportunity during
the hot promo phase of Black Adam
Johnson also wishes for a Black Adam vs
Superman movie in which the two Clash
something that is said to have been
obstructed under departing DC boss
Walter Hamada so far regardless a black
Superman movie is also believed to be in
the works under production by JJ Abrams
The Hollywood Reporter further talked
about Matt Reeves in his plans for the
expansion of the Batman Universe so far
we know about the Batman 2 and an Arkham
Asylum as well as a Penguin series but
the plans won't stop there Reeves is
currently looking for screenwriters and
directors to produce further movie
spin-offs from the world of Gotham City
among them should also be rather unknown
but bizarre characters such as Clayface
scarecrow or Professor Pig assuming that
these movies will be as gloomy as the
Batman we can look forward to some very
unsettling flicks Professor Pig in
particular will live up to his name as
he enjoys kidnapping people to turn them
into slaves and human animal hybrids by
means of cruel operations besides
various Batman projects the completion
of the script for Wonder Woman 3 is also
imminent an additional key player in
future DC films is the suicide squad
director James Gunn together with
Aquaman and Shazam producer Peter Safran
he will soon be working on a new DC
project although at present he is still
busy finishing Peacemaker season two
what kind of future project it will be
and if there is any connection to the
suicide squad is unfortunately unclear
news on a possible but flash sequel is
also available after leading actor Ezra
Miller accumulated one scandal after the
other over a long period of time he
recently returned to the set for
reshoots and has publicly apologized the
script for a sequel is reported to have
already been completed by Aquaman and
the lost kingdom author David Leslie
Johnson McGoldrick the only question
remaining is whether Miller will also
start in the sequel so far Warner
Brothers has stood by Miller in spite of
his escapades yet the 30-year-old is
still awaiting trial in January for
burglary which could even send him to
prison should he be found guilty so it
remains exciting at DC and Warner
Brothers at least there are now some
movies and Series in the works that fans
can look forward to after the Strategic
realignment under Warner CEO David
zaslot and the cancellation of Batgirl
and scoob too
since August the new She-Hulk Series has
been available on Disney plus before its
release the series made negative
headlines due to a trailer with bad CGI
and thus the signs were anything but
good as is now reflected in the viewer
ratings while many critics like at least
a few aspects of the series the opinions
of the majority of MCU fans were
anything but positive overall without
going into detail we must admit that the
general reception is mediocre at best
now the big question is what's next for
She-Hulk and Title Character Jennifer
Walters after the brilliant finale if we
look at the general series policy within
the MCU it is noticeable that only very
few series actually get the chance for a
second season including the Beloved Loki
series for example even lead actress
Tatiana mazlani considers the chance for
a second season to be slim as she
recently acknowledged in an interview of
extra internally she had not heard
anything about a second season likewise
conceivable and in our view no not
unlikely is an appearance of Jennifer
Walters AKA She-Hulk in one of the
upcoming Marvel movies perhaps even with
her cousin Bruce Banner or her ex-client
Abomination one possible appearance
would be in Captain America New World
Order since actor Tim Blake Nelson also
shows up there as leader at the moment
we unfortunately have little choice but
to resort to speculations so we hope to
get an official announcement for Marvel
very soon what are your thoughts on the
She-Hulk series do you like the new MCU
character and would you consider
watching a second season or are you
among the fans who were let down by the
performance feel free to let us know in
the comments
whip The Equalizer a rather brutal and
emotional Blockbuster was released in
2014 with Denzel Washington in the
leading role even though the four years
later released sequel could not build on
its popular predecessor without flaws a
third film was commissioned right away
last month director Antoine Fuqua
revealed that in The Equalizer 3 we will
learn more about the past of the main
character Robert McCall in addition
there will be a change of scenery as
most of the action will now take place
in Europe more precisely in Italy will
McCall have to deal with the kosa Nostra
this time well as of this week there are
at least first images from the set on
the picturesque Amalfi Coast where
filming is currently underway in
addition to Washington co-stars Dakota
Fanning and Gaia scudilaro can both be
seen as well returning director Antoine
Fuqua also made sure to pose with his
actors in The snapshots so far so good
however the images do not allow us to
draw any conclusions about the storyline
as there are no known shots of the
appearing characters yet so for the time
being we will have to wait for more
information about the plot and a release
date has unfortunately not been set
either
are you thrilled about the latest MCU
and DC developments or are you more
curious about what's going to happen on
the desert Planet well if none of that's
enough for you we've got you covered
check out our brand new Deadpool 3 movie
preview and get excited for some
anti-hero action as always enjoy
watching and we hope to see you next
week
laughs
[Music]